وكان به استكمال القطعه الناقصه من مشهد
هيمنه اليمين المتطرف على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه المزمع تشكيلها حزب الكود
بزعامه رئيس الوزراء المكلف اليمين
نتنياهو يقول انه تم التوصل الى اتفاق مع
حزب اليمني متطرف للانضمام الى اختلاف
الحكومي لكود اوضح ان الحزب هو الصهيونيه
الدينيه وانه سيمنح السيطره على وزاره
الماليه بالتناوب الى جانب حقائب اخرى
اتفاق يمنح نتنياه السيطره حتى الان على
46 من مقاعد الكنيسه البالغ عددها 120
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ذكرت في دورها ان
بتسيل سوموتريتش زعيم حزب الصهيونيه
الدينيه سيتولى بنفسه منصبه وزير الماليه
ويدعم هذا الحزب توسيع سياده الاسرائيليه
في الضفه الغربيه المحتله والعل اكثر من
انتشر في الفتره الماضيه عن زعيمه ما قاله
مخاطبا اعضاء الكنيسه بانهم موجودون
بالخطا لان بن غوريون اي رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي السابق لم يكمل المهمه بالقضاء
عليها بحسب القناه العبريه السابعه وياتي
الاتفاق بعد ان حقق تحالف نتنياهو اليمني
فوزا مريحه في الانتخابات التي جرت في
الاول من نوفمبر وكان قد تحالف مع اليمني
المتطرف اثمار بن كبير اترم منحه وعدا
بتولي وزاره الامن الوطني وهو ما حصل وهي
حقيبه تتمتع بالسلطات على الشرطه في
اسرائيل والضفه الغربيه المحتله